bisschen wasser abgefüllt in alte
plastikflaschen die einzige leitung
inmitten von müllbergen maria na wai und
ihr sohn holen verpflegung in moria dem
flüchtlingslager auf der griechischen
insel lesbos die leute waschen hier ihr
geschirr sich selbst und trinken auch
noch davon und dann werden sie krank
anderes wasser gibt es hier nicht
marianna weil ihr mann und der
elfjährige sohn sind flüchtlinge aus dem
iran vor einem monat kamen sie übers
meer aus der türkei auf lesbos an
seitdem leben sie in diesem zelt im camp
maria hier ist es nicht sicher alle
menschen hier sind vor dem krieg oder
anderen problemen nach griechenland
geflohen
doch auch hier im camp sind wir nicht in
sicherheit wir frauen können abends
nicht raus aus dem zelt weil wir alle
angst haben
maria ist hoffnungslos überfüllt
ausgelegt auf 3000 menschen leben
inzwischen 12.000 auf engstem raum in
containern und außerhalb des zauns in
zelten die zustände menschenunwürdig auf
100 flüchtlinge kommt eine toilette für
eine mahlzeit steht man drei stunden in
der schlange
die stimmung im lager latent angespannt
oft bricht gewalt aus vor mehreren
wochen wurde ein jugendlicher stoppen
vergangenen sonntag starben bei einem
feuer eine frau und ihr suchen die un
hcr ist sehr besorgt über die aktuelle
situation die kritisch ist wir fordern
die regierung auf die menschen schneller
auf das festland zu bringen
im inland seit monaten schwelt der strom
der flüchtenden wieder an
täglich kommen neue boote nach lesbos
allein im august waren es 8000 menschen
sie kommen aus der nur zwölf kilometer
entfernten türkei die türkische
regierung soll gemäss abkommen mit der
eu genau das verhindern
doch forderte die türkei zuletzt eine
bessere verteilung der gelder
gestern reiste bundesinnenminister
seehofer nach ankara blitzbesuch um den
fragilen deal zu stabilisieren
zunächst muss man sagen dass der
migrationsdruck gewaltig ist der
waschung gewaltige in den letzten jahren
aber er steigt jetzt noch mal massiv an
das spürte die türkei ganz besonders
sowohl afghanen vision und deshalb
müssen wir schauen wie dieser pakt
zwischen der europäischen union und der
türkei bekräftigt werden kann
am mittag fliegt seehofer weiter nach
athen will dort mit der griechischen
regierung lösungen finden vielleicht ein
hoffnungsschimmer für die menschen in
moria